we're ready for baseball
as the rockies look to keep a good thing
going here at coors field how
austin gomber will deal with luis suarez
action as rios with a fly ball head back
in a deep right center field and it's
off the wall
ureas continues swinging a hot bat
as he takes the turn he'll stop at
second and that's how you want to start
your saturday night
he has been swinging about well four
rbis in the series
there's that change up and able to wait
back nicely on it was up it was out away
from
urias willia domes got willie adamus who
shoots one down the line
in right there that's gonna get to the
corner urrios will score
back to back doubles and the brewers
quickly on the board tonight
yeah jumping on some pitches that gobber
making mistakes on huh
only two right-handed batters going to
the opposite field first uria sanella
thomas shooting
one down the right field line javi
garcia runners on the corners
one pitch to garcia swing a line drive
towards the third baseman
it's glove to second for one on to first
not in time it's an rbi fielder's choice
it's two-nothing milwaukee great stabbed
by mcmahon to start the front end of a
potential double play
but garcia runs too well legs it out
picks up rbn number 39
pitching of adrian hauser and there is a
bouncing
ball inside third base rolling down the
line
rymel digging for two again yelich's
throw
is not in time a leadoff double
for rymel tapia ross 16-game hitting
streak now 14 doubles
this is the 13th double right down the
line then he's nestled into
second base and it's first and third
no one out and the rockies putting
together a counter punch here at the
bottom of the first
one oh to charlie he's jammed it's a
slow roller the only play is going to be
to first as robertson makes the play
to second goes dazza home comes tapia
and the iraqis have cut the lead in half
2-1 milwaukee daza into scoring position
with one out for trevor story
and it smoked off the globe
just like that 3-0
swinging story with his 28th rbi
and he's getting himself locked in last
five ball games he is now eight for 18.
top he has 16 hits two with two outs and
runners in scoring position
this ball toward the middle of the
diamond on through base hit
right up top here is going to bring home
elias diaz and the rockies take a 3-2
lead
in the second so make that now
17 hits with two outs and runners in
scoring position
austin gomberg left the ball game
precautionary reasons
left forearm tightness right-hander
jolie the brewers quickly with runners
in scoring position
yelich now with an opportunity
and yelling to the ground ball knocked
down by mcmahon a run will score is a
play over at first
rbi ground ball from yelich as urease is
in and for a moment that was going to
eat up
ryan mcmahon but christian gets the job
done and we are tied at three
here's avasail garcia two and two
strike three on the inside corner
garcia even less happy than he was a
couple of moments ago
two outs just a terrific slow breaking
ball
at the knees with late break a 3-3 game
top of four bases loaded for adrian
hauser
in kicks and fires and a cold strike
three to hauser
and there's out number one the strikeout
by jolie shasin
so now maria 1-0 pitch swung on and line
to story it's second flick to rogers at
the bag
a little bit late diving back in was
robertson two down though as urias hit
that one on the button
now william davis 2-2 pitch swing
and a miss jolisha seen with
another big strikeout and he leaves the
bases
loaded in the fourth one to diaz
there's a ground ball it should be two
there's one
and there's two the pick from jace
peterson
six four three there's the ground ball
hauser
let's say he's been looking for he's
been getting all night here's the one
two
and then we'll ring him up straight
three call it inning over
3-3 game as we move into the bottom of
the fifth inning
men on the corners nobody out got
charlie blackman right now
ground ball to third nobody was at the
bag because of the shift
the rockies take the lead and dazza
is in second for a potential
fifth run topia making it happen again
and for charlie gets it in play he's
over three but he's got two rbis tonight
ryan mcmahon
and there's a base hit oh third
dozen cuts the bag he'll come home and
the rockies have a two-run lead
another timely hit from ryan mcmahon
now the two out daggers those are the
good ones rockies are up five
to three and that's it this ball is
tater deep center field
makes the catch
didn't think there was any way
you don't see him any better than that
dazza racing back
right before the barrier timed his jump
perfectly
came down right into the padding and oh
man is that a catch
brewers have the tying run at first with
avisail garcia coming to the plate
one strike pitch to hobby let's back up
the middle in the center field to base
hit
adonis rounding third he's going to
score
it's a one-run game as garcia with an
rbi
knock here in the seventh third hit for
the brewers with a man in scoring
position
now there's a pair on with two outs for
the rockies and ryan mcmahon coming to
the plate
on the one-two swung on and missed
elevated fastball
he blew him away with 90 elevated and
mcmahon
strikes out and the inning is over tyler
kinley on to try to
close it out colton wong as a pinch
hitter
line drive but it's right at
positioning was perfect long lines it
out to the second baseman william thomas
will be the hitter
kenley with a 1-2 and adams with a fly
ball
[Applause]
goes opposite field in the ninth
and the brewers lead it in colorado
don't sleep on the crew in denver so now
it's brendan rodgers
he's the last hope into the rogers
and here it comes struck it out fastball
to win the game
brewers come from behind and take down
the rockies
six to five